[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the president they
battled not for control and domination
but for liberty democracy and self-rule
they pressed on for love and home and
country the main streets the schoolyards
the churches and neighbors the families
and communities that gave us men such as
these they were sustained by the
confidence that America can do anything
because we are a noble nation with a
virtuous people praying to a righteous
God the exceptional might came from a
truly exceptional spirit the abundance
of courage came from an abundance of
faith the great deeds of an army came
from the great depths of their love the
men behind me will tell you that they
are just the lucky ones as one of them
recently put it all the heroes are
buried here but we know what these men
did we knew how brave they were they
came here and saved freedom and then
they went home and showed us all what
freedom is all about the blood that they
spilled the tears that they shed the
lives that they gave the sacrifice that
they made did not just win a battle
it did not just win a war those who
fought here won a future for our nation
they won the survival of our
civilization and they showed us the way
to love cherish and defend our way of
life for many centuries to come